[Music]
the press has not treated these
incredible people who have done such a
great job they haven't treated unfairly
everything we did I was criticized
because I was too early if I waited
longer it would have been you would have
incurred if I went way early if I went
three months earlier I would have been
criticized you know criticized for being
way too early and I don't mind being
criticized but not when they're wrong
not when people have done a great job
yes see the briefing yesterday and the
briefing yesterday basically was an
all-out brawl between the press and the
president had nothing to do with US
Senator Lindsey Graham watch too he's
chairman of the Senate Judiciary
Committee obviously Republican South
Carolina senator the look back Sunday
with the New York Times picked up by
every news organization pointed all
fingers at basically the president for
dropping the ball and not acting sooner
the president fought back well where's
the truth line well number one mr.
president the American people understand
what you've done for them in this effort
to destroy Trump no matter the cost of
the country is getting a bit old and
it's pissing a lot of people off the
president made four really important
decisions to save American lives
number one he shut down travel to China
and Europe and a way to keep hundreds of
thousands of people from being affected
he declared a national emergency to give
the country the tools to fight back that
that was a major decision he rejected
the herd mentality of letting it run
rampant through the country people build
up immunity a couple million people
would have died if that had been the
case and finally I think the the most
important thing the president has done
is unleash the private sector in testing
and trying to develop drugs by giving
FDA waivers for therapies and vaccines
to speed up the process so I think the
president has made really hard calls
well and we're going to be well below
the hundred thousand minimum expected
and it's due to his leadership and the
American people working to get
what do you think about that timeline
I've never seen a briefing and I don't
know if you have where they the
president put together an entire can you
hear me Lindsey senator yes Harris you
can hear us
so what do you think of that video that
he put together he put together a
timeline of him saying in January travel
ban then he had people in the media
saying this is ridiculous he's going too
far you had Biden saying xenophobia and
then it would have another soundbite of
President Trump in February than another
one and the media criticizing him and
now the media criticizing him for not
doing enough so I thought that was
pretty pretty smart on on his part and
then he also included sound bites of the
governor of New York and governor of
California who are both Democrats
praising him well number one we're going
to have an election in November but
people are dying right now and this
president is doing everything humanly
possible to work with anybody that will
work with him do you know when
impeachment ended February the 6th we
voted to acquit the President and
Democratic leaders who are criticizing
the president now wanted to extend the
trial for weeks to call more witnesses
Joe Biden criticized President Trump
when he invoked the Chinese travel ban
he's trying to rewrite history not
President Trump I do believe that the
president's biggest decision was
stopping travel from China and Europe
declaring a national emergency so we
could take the full resources of the
federal government and put them into
play here and waiving a lot of rules and
regulations so that when get vaccines
and drug therapies hopefully by this
fall or late summer so we'll have an
election over all this but you got to
remember the Democratic Party on
February the 6th was asking the Senate
send it to stay in session to get more
witnesses these are the people who are
criticized yeah no kidding you know
senator after the presidential directive
about people stay at home for the pretty
much the entire month of April there are
now millions of people who are out of
work they're trying to file for
unemployment
insurance through their states I was
talking to the Kansas State Secretary of
Labor and she and her team explained to
me that normally in a week Kansas might
process 1,300 unemployment claims
now it's fifty five thousand a week and
they've had to quadruple the Qualla the
call center and you know they're trying
to get it on the website but people have
been trying for weeks and they still
haven't been able to file for
unemployment and I know that is one of
your main concerns yeah in South
Carolina we had a 40 100 percent
increase in unemployment claims 85,000
last week in a normal week it's about
2000 our unemployment system is working
pretty well here we've got major
problems like everybody else with a
volume but we've processed a hundred and
eighty thousand claims the small
business loan program that you talked
about earlier in the in the show is
designed to keep small businesses from
going bankrupt while we're in mitigation
and it's designed to keep their
employees on the payroll here's the
problem the unemployment benefits in
South Carolina are twenty three dollars
an hour to be unemployed you've got a
lot of small businesses trying to keep
their people on the payroll paying 16
and 17 dollars an hour one program is
undercutting the other and we've got to
get that fixed you do and you have to do
the ratio between what they do with
their money I just don't understand why
you can't go back in there and just fix
it this is like that we have to make her
that talk to that that says they agree
but no one's fixing it but on another
note
you got it real another reality check
last night as the tornado slammed into
your hometown of Seneca South Carolina
how's everybody doing well we lost one
person BorgWarner a manufacturing plant
a really good company got hit hard and
the person got killed was working there
at night as a contractor normally they
would be running a third shift at that
plant with 200 people and it's a just a
blessing from God that they were not
open because their coronavirus it was a
yes three hurricane
at 3:30 in the morning I thought a train
was coming through my house so my
hometown got hit really hard we lost
nine people in South Carolina to these
tornados that went all over the state
we'll get through it the governor has
been great but we've got to fix this
loan program I don't mean to change
topics but the 7525 split needs to
change and there are people applying for
this small business loan that really are
liquid as they can be and they're taking
advantage of it the money should be for
Main Street and as some people are
abusing this system we can't keep
employees yeah
you can't keep employees if they have no
owner people have to remember there has
to be an owner and employees not just in
pain I don't know what it takes get
through these people all right senator
thank you so much Thanks thank you I
think we got to go so we're out of time
we'll talk to you soon thanks so much
senator